6 35 here on a Wednesday morning all
right we're into Extra Innings now for
the Oakland A's and a potential move
here to Las Vegas however there may not
be some clarity at the legislative
session on a tax incentive package to
build a new baseball stadium here
sources tell the 8 news now
investigators the team State lawmakers
and Clark County could announce a
financing deal today as first reported
by the Nevada independent the tentative
package would include 325 million
dollars in tax incentives from the state
however no legislation with any concrete
details has been introduced yet Clark
County would also have to approve this
proposal from State lawmakers the A's
have a deal to build a 1.5 billion
dollar Stadium at the site of the
Tropicana they just want State funding
to help make it happen